thank you good afternoon this talk is
mostly addressed to the high end of the
mill CPU family it's a family in the
sense of the 360 is a family and at the
low end the kinds of issues that he
speaks of are essentially not a problem
that mean an x86 can decode for
instructions in a cycle if all you need
is for that and this is a stabber start
it's when you're at the high end and you
need to pull a whole lot more other
talks other times or questions I can
remark on what we do at the low end they
are equally innovative as what we have
here the this being a university class
for credit we'll do the traditional and
start with a short quiz you all know the
various kinds of architectures there's
accumulator machines and stack machines
and this that and the other so if I give
you a set of specifications for an
existing chip can you tell me what
architecture that ship is when is
incidentally this is an existing
top-of-the-line product from a major
manufacturer for course each one of
which can handle four operations per
cycle you may need freon cooling 30 300
megahertz using a hundred and thirty
Watts that's where the freon comes in 52
Giga operations per second for 880 or $5
list anyone want to guess what the
architecture of that chip is don't all
speak at once
someone yes
some random 8086 but the architecture
not what is this organizers it a stack
machine of like that one it is in fact a
general-purpose out-of-order superscalar
which in particular is an Intel Xeon now
free on one more example this one's got
one core issuing eight operations per
cycle clock rate of not quite 500
megahertz only 1.1 watts am I in the way
of people seeing the this I can move
over if it would help only three Giga
operations but also only $17 anyone want
to guess what the architectural category
that ship belongs to is it a DSP
it's a DSP and in particular it's an
inorder V liw DSP and it is a Texas
Instruments DSP now in abstract terms
these two are very very different but if
you compare them which is better
well it's apples and oranges of course
but over the last decade that the
industry is sort of consolidated itself
into a accepted figure of Merit which is
a good rule of thumb that figure of
Merit its performance per watt per
dollar
and obviously you do need certain other
things you need the IO compliment that
you have and everything else but just
for purposes of general comparisons this
has become the standard now there's our
to course our to chips and the
out-of-order superscalar is your half
omits for your watch and your dollar the
in order DSP gives you a hundred and
ninety five MIPS for your watt and your
dollar it's a factor of four hundred now
you'd think that by now somebody would
said seeing the market opportunity in
this and tried to arbitrage that number
away but that difference has been around
for a long time so why is there a 400x
difference one is simple the the Texas
insulin with chip is a 32-bit chip you
want to do 64-bit addressing space you
need the superscalar another is total
raw horsepower it takes an awful lot of
those Texas's some chips to add up to
the total number of opposite you can get
through the superscalar but what really
makes the difference is that the
workloads are incompatible a the TI chip
running on a general-purpose workload is
truly awful it is designed for things
which stay in loops forever software
pipeline loops and code that is just
full of random flow of control and
random memory references which is
characteristics of your general-purpose
code it tends to be very bad on now the
Intel chip would make a fairly decent
DSP if you could have you buy enough RIA
so the problem the fundamental problem
is the signal processing is not the same
as general-purpose
which defined our goal and our technical
challenge as a company when we started
out to design a new processor from
scratch
we wanted to provide DSP numbers on
general-purpose workloads
well the numbers I'm about to give you
are coming out of sim or our best guess
for marketing we do not have something
which is actually for sale at this point
take it with a large grain of salt the
particular trip is to course issuing 33
operations per cycle each at a clock
rate of 1200 megahertz is in 28 watts
and producing not quite 80 Giga
operations per second total and our best
guess is 85 dollars so those as the
gentleman sitting over there who
probably may I have a difference of
opinion that's our gold CPU architecture
one of several I said it was a family
and in fact into a core one and you're
getting 33 MIPS for what's per dollar
out of that configuration now in that
list of what goal does you may have
noticed that we get rid of this light at
all possible or other people not getting
glare off the screen excellent much
better that number 33 is just completely
beyond what existing ships do your x86
max out at 4 or 5 some ships well the TI
goes up to 8 the upper limit of anything
commercial I've ever seen is like 10 or
11 that can be issued simultaneously why
on earth would you want to put out 33
ops the answer is even in general
purpose code 80% of all the code is in
loops and if you can software pipeline
those loops which of course
is what they're all the DSPs do then you
have in fact unbounded ILP you can soak
up every adder you can throw at it
forever but in current state of the art
rather few general-purpose chips can be
pipelined at least on conventional
architectures the solution find a way to
pipeline almost all loops and we have
done that but that's not the subject of
today's talk it's real hardware at it
few people realize that how little of a
chips area and power are consumed with
the actual functional units the adders
and multipliers and things like that six
percent of the total chip is a usual
number for that you could double the
number of and still be only at twelve
percent of the ship the constraint is
not that you can't fit more adders and
multipliers on the constraint is that
you can't interconnect them and you
can't feed them with instructions this
talk is about feeding them with
instructions once you have done that
well you've taken care of the loop part
of the problem M does law still exists
and we handle the open code non loop
code as well but that also is not this
talk so if you're going to try 33
operations per cycle peak how you going
to do it well of the various possible
bottlenecks within the machine by far
actually the biggest problem is decoding
this stuff there's two basic models for
instruction layout you can have fixed or
format instructions where every
instruction is the same length your
typical RISC instruction set they are
dirt easy to parse you just drop the
thing into a decoder and the neck
100 recoder and next think of the
decoder and away you go
Bob's your uncle but if each instruction
is 32 bits and you have 30 through of
them 33 of them the total space is a
hundred and 32 bytes that's over two
cache lines at 64 bytes per cache line
and you're simply not going to be
getting sixty two cache lines per cycle
out of your top-level instruction cache
so that's pretty hopeless
it's an ouch the other side of that
problem is instruction cache pressure
you can't have unlimited instruction
cache everybody needs more instruction
cache but the bigger they are the
further they are from the functional
units and the longer they take and you
start paying and in your cycle time well
if you have a typical size of a 32 K
instruction cache and they are occupying
132 bytes each you only get 248
instructions in that cache and as a rule
of thumb you need at least a thousand
instructions at your top level cache so
we're a long way from that now the
alternative is variable length
instructions like the x86 instruction
set they are hard to parse Intel is very
very good at her roids and the they
throw hardware and they throw power and
they throw everything else at parsing
and they only be are able to decode four
instructions at a time and then only if
it's a restricted subset of the
instruction set because if you some of
the really lollapalooza instructions in
the x86 instruction set you get one
outer baby so we actually have got a
very compact instruction set encoding
and we run around 15 bits per operation
for per ad per multiply per load
whatever on the average we run around 15
bits
put an awful lot of effort being compact
because of this destruction cache
problem and that times 33 ops well we're
still around a whole cache line as per
cycle and we really don't want to do
that so that's a little painful - and
the instruction cache pressure well
we've doubled the available a number of
operations or a number of instruction
the cache but we're still nowhere near a
thousand instructions so let me digress
a little bit in order to explain how we
get around this first back at the very
beginning what is it that we're handling
we're handling a stream of instructions
mr. von neumann and company which the
location and the streaming is sequential
thing is indicated by a program counter
you pull in the instruction out drop it
into decode to figure out in terms of
signals what the rest of the machine
should do and then you go execute those
signals that's the logical view the real
world doesn't work like that on modern
machines because you have to grab more
than one instruction per cycle we call a
common term actually the group of
instructions that you're going to grab
per cycle a bundle and the logical
hardware will grab that group a whole
bundle out of the instruction stream
where the start of the bundle is
indicated by the program counter drop it
into decode and that in turn winds up
being fanned out to multiple operation
functional units if these are fixed
length instructions decode is easy you
simply have one decoder for each
position in the bundle drop them in but
two-bit this is why risk was I was able
to fit the trip back at the beginning of
the rest days and away you go
if however they're easy and big yes if
you go for variable length instructions
well you start having an issue where
does the next bundle start
this bundle along here hello how many
bytes that is varies from its right exit
cycle to cycle and we need in if we're
going to get the next one
in the following cycle we need to be
able to find the end of it we also need
to be able to find the start points of
each of the instructions within the
bundle that has polynomial cost as and
indeed this is why Intel is not able to
get more than four
well polynomial is not fine event is
three but it's not very fine at all
event is thirty so your way around that
well here was the first insight because
it's polynomial you can cars two bundles
of length n much faster much easier much
less power much less trouble than one
bundle of lengths to win okay
just normal polynomial so with each
bundle in half and have two streams of
half bundles that's what it looks like
you have to program counters one
pointing into each of this half bundle
streams each one feeds its own decoder
this one handling that not just one
handling that but the T coders only have
half the load they're not trying to do
30 they're trying to do 15 well welcome
to polynomial that's a big good thing
there are two physical streams and one
logical stream this is a single thread
of execution this is not a vector
arithmetic this is not a GPU it's you're
this kind of thing that you're doing in
your laptop or whatever it's a single
thread of execution
where the secrets of instructions split
up into two streams the bottle of course
is how do your branch trip you've got to
program counters and if you're going to
do a branch or a call you need to be
able to send both program counters to
their new location well a branch
operation carries an effective address
but if you had try and have a branch
operation with two effective addresses
in it well suddenly your code started to
get bigger and then you have to think
about what does a function pointer look
like when it's got two addresses in the
function pointer this doesn't work very
well well to explain that I need to back
off a little bit and introduce a term
most of you will be familiar with the
extended basic block he says sometimes
called super blocks this is the sequence
of code which has got a single entry
point called the head and may have
multiple exit points where it goes to
someplace else we are unusual in that we
permit embedded calls inside a and ABB
but that's not relevant to today's talk
so your two program counters are
actually describing not so much a stream
of instructions as a sequence of e bb's
we enter one that will branch to the
head of another that will eventually go
to the head of another and so forth and
be just like there's an e BB in the full
bundles this also a pair of a B B's in
the half bundle streams of it's two of
them as shown the branches can only
target an e BB entry point this includes
calls it is not possible to jump into
the middle of it
by definition that's what they are
so take two of our half eb beefs this is
color coded to indicate the two half
bundles which will decode an issue in
the same cycle the two blues will go
together they are actually part of the
same instruction this was split in half
the two Purple's will go together and so
forth
so that's the color coding merely to
indicate which of the two halves belong
together
they're organized from lower remember to
higher memory as usual execution order
so you rotate one in memory now one of
them executes toward increasing
addresses and the other one is going to
execute in terms of decreasing addresses
notice we still have them color coded
that was a run together now join them
together head to head
the entry point of both the dark-blue
bundle is now at the same address
it's just that they decode in the
opposite direction consequently the
branch problem is solved your branch
here you branch both programs there and
one goes one way and one goes the other
way so to take a branch some random code
of which is that we are interested is
jump operation the jump will carry an
effective address and that effective
address goes to the entry point of the
now joined to half EB B's joined into a
single EBP note you're now always
jumping at to the head of an e BB
logically but you're jumping to the
middle of an e BB physically now how
that works there's two program counters
they point there we have to bring up the
decode they execute you remember we were
doing decode we pull off the two central
bundles we move the program counters to
the next bundle the decode does its
thing sends the signals to the execute
execute execute pull off the next pair
down and execute and so on there we go
keep on going until somebody does a
branch whereupon the two program
counters both go off to someplace else
yes the cache lines fit into this well
let me get to it that will come up in a
minute the short answer is that this two
caches one for each three bit decoder
now for historical reasons internally
our two streams we've refer to as the
execute or xu flow stream and the flow
stream and in fact all of the operations
that are things like adds and multiplies
are in one stream and all of the
operations that contain effective
addresses such as branches or loads and
stores or on the other stream and this
winds up giving us a pretty good
bandwidth balance between the two sides
so an X we see there is the program
counter for the exercise and FBC is the
program counter for the flow side and
when you take a branch you go to the
entry point increasing addresses this
way decreasing address is that way but
both program counters go to the same
place after some number of cycles later
the program counters have diverged
physical layout in cache everybody needs
to get their cache as close to the
decoders as they possibly can because
there's a critical distance that
critical distance is from the far side
of the cache to the front side of the
decoder wires are time so you can only
get those so far apart and that's what
puts your upper limit on either paying
for it in your clock rate or
alternatively paying for it in the size
of your instruction cache now you can in
fact have a bigger cache
but you also wind up with a bigger
critical distance this is what the mill
looks like at the same abstract level
the two decoders are on either side of
the execution units and outbound of each
of them are the two top level
instruction caches that's our critical
distance you see it's the same as the
short critical distance up here on the
left but the total capacity is the same
as the large critical distance we have
doubled the instruction cache capacity
at no increase in per operation power
area or heat now that gets a stand to
having a bundle in the decoder a
half-sized bundled into the coder now we
have to take the bundle apart the bundle
is itself variable length and filled
with variable length operations we issue
one instruction per cycle this
disregarding stalls of course and that
will be two half bundles there can be a
large number of independent operations
go ahead and tow 233 on that gold that I
showed you and but they all issue
together we are an inorder statically
scheduled to machine like a VL i W in
this respect and they execute in
parallel the internal structure of each
bundle every bundle starts with a header
following the header there's some number
of independent blocks and containing
operations and the operations in any
single block are all exactly the same
size their fixed size within the block
consequently if you can isolate a single
block they are easy to decode just like
any other fixed size format so the
problem reduces
isolating blocks each one of those boxes
are variable size they may not all be
present the machine bundles are byte
aligned but the individual operations
and hence the blocks are bit aligned and
this means there's usually an alignment
hole in the middle not yet wasted bits
you'll see later so how that generic
farm gets decoded assumed magically that
you have an instruction buffer that it's
got a left online bundling undo buffer
probably would be a better term that
header contains among other things the
bike count of the whole bundle
consequently we can send that it's
furthermore it's in a fixed position
here so it's easy to get out we can send
that bike count to a bundle shifter that
in one cycle will move the whole thing
over and bring in the next bundle we
don't have to parse it to figure out how
long it is we tell it how long it is the
bike count is right in there actually
it's a tap count on the shifter but then
effectively it's a bike now in addition
besides the bike count the bundle by
count there is a operation count for
each one of the blocks there's something
that says we've got three operations in
block one and five in block two or etc
this is all encoded in that header now
the header itself is fixed size
consequently if we have this thing left
aligned in a bundle buffer that point is
known because the header is fixed size
that point is fixed consequently we can
drop all of the putative block once all
of the things that might be a block one
operation
into block one decoder say that the
maximum number of block one ops at the
machine we can handle is nine just to
pick a number well we can drop nine
blocks of nine hunts the bits into block
one decode there may only be three of
them but we'll figure that out later and
throw the XS away so we can immediately
begin decode a black one in addition
because we know what how many are
actually present in block one will send
that counter to that decoder and shifter
so it can knows how much to throw away
in addition because we know how many
there are we know where that is
and at the same time as we're shifting
the whole bundle a different shifter
it's going to be starting there and
shifting block two into a block to
buffer well one cycle later this is what
you got the whole bundle shifter shifted
our whole bundle over but if you stop
and think about it this is the header of
the following bundle if you stop and
think about it if the header is left
aligned in the bundle buffer then
necessarily the end of the previous
instruction is right aligned in the
bundle buffer
we're pulling both of them along
consequently we know we're blocks free
is and we can drop all of blocks free
into its own personal decoder by three
is soft meanwhile we had already shifted
block two and do block to zone buffer
that's properly aligned and that gets
dropped in now I've shown it for three
blocks it happens on the mill that each
side does in fact I have an encoding
with three blocks because it turns out
this is all we needed but the general
principle here is applicable to an
arbitrarily large number each cycle
you're going to get two more blocks
working
in from both ends we decode from both
ends of the bundle one in the first
cycle block one and two every succeeding
cycle after that
now I mentioned that alignment hole in
the middle anything any machine with a
statically scheduled layout has to deal
with the situation that there's nothing
for the machine to do sometimes we're in
the middle of a floating-point multiply
and there ain't nothing to do until
we're done and this is a standard V liw
problem and every the liw problem has
some way of encoding how do you do a no
op cheap because you don't want to have
to have a whole full-size bundle full of
nothing but no ups so in our case we
encode what's called a lag count in the
alignment hole if that's zero the
alignment hole value refers to the other
side
if that's zero he issues immediately if
on the other hand if that's one he lags
for one cycle before issuing each one
encodes the lag of the other side
consequently no ops because they're in
fact encoded in the alignment hole costs
nothing they're already there now of
course if it happens that you don't have
an alignment hole because all the bits
happen to line up exactly the right way
then you have to explicitly encode it
and yes the mystery the instruction set
supports that but it's happens extremely
rarely hello there we go now putting all
this together I'm going to give you a
very rough sketch of the front end of
the mil pipeline instructions start out
in memory or the l2 as lines standard
cache layout
the prefetch we have a precise prefetch
this talk will also not address
prediction but our prediction machinery
has a precise prefetcher it's not an
approximate or algorithmic prefetch -
its precise and the amount of time it
takes to get from memory or l2 as driven
by the prefetch or it does vary and the
stuff will eventually wind up in your l1
top-level instruction cache still as
lines from there a separate step is
fetch to get lines from the l1 and that
is the the cycles f0 through have f1 and
f2 because it typically takes 3 cycles
to get a value out of the instruction
cache up to where you're going to use it
this is pretty standard in terms of
physical layout and you'll wind up in
the l0 we are unusual in that there is a
top-level instruction cache which is a
level above the logical level of on the
data side it's much smaller it's fully
associative and you can think of it as
being a transient buffer for
instructions as opposed to a full-scale
cache but it's still it's a cache now
that has a one cycle delay to go into
the bundle shifter the top level of what
you saw a few slides ago and that's in
the d0 cycle which immediately follows
the f2 cycle the bundle is taken apart
in d0 d1 and d2
there is no issue stage that's where it
would appear and things go directly into
the adders as operations and as within a
execute pipeline this your simple things
take one cycle and more complicated
things take
there's no retire stage either so the
add to add data flow time is zero cycles
I can have a full data flow dependent
add cycle after cycle after cycle after
cycle for a one cycle add and we have a
four cycle miss predict penalty if we're
coming out of the L zero we are commonly
coming out of the L zero or in cases
like for example you've got an
if-then-else set a saddle and you went
down the wrong way and both sides will
be in the LZ rows and that's a common
situation if it's not in the L zero
you're going to have to add the two two
and a two and a half actually in a
peculiar way cycles to get out of the L
1 and if you miss there and wind up all
the way going all the way to D Ram well
you can suck your thumb for 400 cycles
so in sum the mill uses a split stream
double ended decoding technique because
there are three of those blocks on each
side there's a total of six blocks in
each and over 33 this means that each
block has on the average five or six
possible positions to hold an operation
but because the decoder only has to deal
with three we have no greater problem
and in fact actually less problem than
in x86 has to get out I get a four done
so in essence we are we are decoding 33
individual ops maximum peak of course at
full speed there are two program
counters they're following two
instruction bundle streams they are
drawn from two instruction caches they
feed two decoders one of which runs
backwards
both bundles are past parts from both
ends for each side the instruction size
15 bits times 17 ops knot times 33 ops
because we split them well that's only
32 bytes and that's tolerable we can the
memory hierarchy can feed 32 bytes to to
a decoder per cycle without that much
trouble and other trips do it to the
instruction cache pressure because we
have twice as much cash between having
small operations and twice as much cash
we're over that magic number over a
thousand instructions per in the cache
the decode rate 30 plus operations per
cycle
this is instruction encoding the stuff
that I talked about here are things that
have gone in in the patent filings we
are madly in the process of doing more
patent filings and well I welcome
questions some of the answers will be
I'm sorry but the patent for that hasn't
gone in yet and I can't talk about it
but I can talk about other aspects of
the mill or more about this if you see
fit
coming up in usenix we're going to be
talking about the architecture of the
Machine the basic category remember when
we started there was a VL iw chip and
there was an out-of-order superscalar
the mill is not one of those categories
it is a belt machine that's a new
category and it has well let me put it
this way there are no general registers
and the programming model is quite
different and that will be presented at
ear snakes coming up in September we'll
be talking about the way our memory
systems subsystems works for the I
Triple E and we have a technical mailing
list that you can sign up for and you'll
get announcements of whitepaper
availability and things like that this
is not a marketing mailing list we're
quite a long ways from having something
that we could market so we won't be
marketing to you it's this is tactical
Russians here let me leave that up
Russians comments what would you like to
know yes what these you for not
generalizing it to end streams is the
n-dimensional memory would have why is
there only two instruction streams and
not M so could you generalize it to n
streams and you certainly could but only
with two can you get one address for two
now if we had n dimensional memory and
we could go in four ways but Samsung
just turned me down with my suggestion
that they do a hypercube memory and I
don't know why yes how much of an
improvement do you think there is
decoding thirty instructions rather than
having a sim D that's thirty wide or C
pyp liw on spec a poppy the difficulty
is usually and in some ways you can look
at the way we encode is being very VL i
dub you like the real problem is that
while you occasionally need 30 plus
instructions you frequently need three
and you want an encoding which is
compact for the three case as well as
for the 33 place and it is difficult to
take a conventional VL aw layout and do
that in fact that's essentially what we
did we took started with a conventional
VL IW layout and came up with this so
that we can handle have the same kind of
performance both for big and small it's
purely an encoding issue generally the
size of this block is quite limited in
the general application application how
do you how do you top we start extending
the size of basic blocks well
as with the most posters - superblocks
which is not our technology this is a
well-established compiler technology
most of some approaches to super blocks
attempt to get the maximum length of ABB
that they can and there are standard
techniques frequently called if
conversion for doing so where if then
else's are folded down into data flow is
through the form of conditional moves or
select operations we have a select
operation not a conditional move and so
consequently we do the same there are
two fundamental problems of taking it
much further than what that you'll read
in the literature one of those problems
has to deal with calls calls are very
frequent and if you treat a call as
being the end of an e BB you're in
trouble we are unusual in our definition
in that we do permit embedded calls even
within a single eb b but i need slides
to explain how we do that it's it's been
filed but i without a slide it's not a
good that's something i want to take on
the other problem is how to handle
exceptions and other hazards that occur
in the middle of an e BB if you're
attempting to fold in and and respect a
do speculative execution which your
forces is what if conversion is you have
to be able to deal with the possibility
that an exception happened down the path
that you didn't actually take and there
are various techniques if you want to
see something truly baroque but actually
works fairly well learn learn the
Itanium instruction set and how they
recover from exceptions we don't do it
like that at all but we have a recovery
method such that we are not subject to
exceptions down the wrong path and
consequently can do much more extensive
if conversion and lengthening a vp base
again that's another talk more please
talking about loops now do you have any
constraints then on what kinds of
instructions can be within a bundle like
you said this isn't a vector
architecture this is well it is a vector
every one of those operations can be a
vector up at those 33 however our Mindi
independent scalar ops but the way the
architecture works it's a two
dimensional this Mindi in one dimension
is Cindy and the other dimension and so
any one of those ups could be doing
vector operations except of course
things like branches which are
inherently scalar so it's not a vector
or architecture in the sense that the
GPU is is a vector operation how are
conventional sense the next 36 is a
vector architecture we are not
constrained we there are many ways to
organize your bundle contents in fact
it's this technique can be applied to a
conventional instruction set as well as
the narrow kind a peculiar kind of thing
but a the way we organize it is that we
partition the operation the entire and
structure said to two groups all the
adds are over there all the loads are
over there consequently the decoders are
somewhat simpler because this side
doesn't have to worry about decoding a
load and this side doesn't have to worry
about decoding an act and simpler is
better or lower power etc etc etc that's
the way we do it yes sometimes you wind
up being totally saturated with ads and
the load suicide is doing nothing but
look it's it's purely a matter of load
balancing and it's well worth the cost
yeah you reuse the opcodes on either
side hey again do you use it do I reuse
the bit patterns of the opcodes yes
which also makes things too compact
Ida there's somebody behind you John
somebody over there
I guess not you're up
six processors implicitly are targeting
x86 existing code to run DSP processors
are implicitly targeting DSP problems
and so forth what is the target area
here or what
what's the instruction mix that you're
using in order to make your decision or
to evaluate your performance or to give
the in order to evaluate how to target
markets for the family general purpose
typically in load/store heavy
control-flow hand a heavy and not enough
regularity that you can do anything
useful in the line that you wouldn't
deliver more loops the lowest it's
inherently a 64-bit machine we do not
compete against thirty-two better 16-bit
machines we require the presence of
64-bit address space so the z80 market
is safe from us at the high end we're
way above all existing architectures and
because it's an architectural advantage
not a fab advantage each new node they
get better
what's so the way it's architectural one
of the reasons why we did not Wellcome
several reasons why we did not focus on
the high performance computing market
the floating-point market - two reasons
really
one is that Livermore loops a
conventional processor does a fairly
decent job and we wanted someplace where
we had a larger gain for market entry
reasons the other is that nobody makes
any money building super interpreters
and we're under for the money the
flipside of my question follow-up is
that things that try to be all things to
all people frequently end up not being
real competitive on much of any I'm not
I don't know your design well that's a
critique
many many many years ago one of our
speakers was Bob Halliwell who designed
the Pentium Pro which is basically
everything and all is introduced in the
last 20 years has been I know I'm wealth
on that in his book the pen you know
memoir chronicles thank you I think he
comments that he was he was really glad
that they were constrained in a lot of
ways because that left them target
things that more than any other one
factor more processor architectures have
failed because they didn't accept any
constraints and they wanted to be all
things to all people
privately I'm told that the Pentium the
Itanium may suffer from that that during
the design phase they weren't willing to
accept any compromises and thus they
came up with something of a sort of a
hodgepodge leaping ahead to your
question I think we've adopted the
wisdom of IBM IBM realized they could
not have do a single processor which was
all things to all men they didn't try
they produced a family of nine
processors which were all things to a
whole lot of different men we're doing
exactly the same thing yes did
virtualization come into your design
thinking once virtualization will
control what instructions were seeing in
the caches but once you've pulled up a
line that belongs to you and from that
from that point on it you you decoder
just like you would if you weren't in
there in a virtual environment yes come
knowledge is that general-purpose code
has an ILP of three or four not more so
I really wonder how you get up to the 33
and if you do why didn't you take 66
because there's only 80% of the code in
this Amdahl's law
saying and Pat professor Pat from oh and
Austin did a study in which they took
alpha code straight out of the compiler
in binary and worked out if they had an
unlimited number of functional units
that could feed them at what point in
adding more functional units would be
diminishing returns and their answer was
that you actually didn't need that many
more floating-point units than at least
in their code sample which was all your
usual benchmarks than what a modern
machine has you needed four to six
40-point units but they still had use
for more al use with 24 al use the
parallelism is there it's just not
parallelism that will fit in the it
in a instruction window we don't have
any instruction windows or alternative a
all a memory is the instruction window
depending on how you want to look at if
that 33 is completely wasted in open
code but look at your own code how much
of your code is in loops while they're
little of that code in modern compilers
what can be turned into software
pipelines Hey no sooner does it have
internal flow of control or it's a while
loop or lots of lots of other things and
the compiler throws up his hands and
does not attempt to software pipelining
because it doesn't know how and you can
get a PhD trying to figure out that how
to do better we do not have any compiler
wizardry weird
it's just isn't any the wizardry is in
their architecture and we can in fact
software pipeline because of the way the
architecture works we can software
pipeline through control flow we can
software pipeline
while loops and we software pipeline
reductions and a whole lot of other
things one thing that I will give credit
to the Itanium for Bob Braille realized
the software pipelines mattered and that
for a high end machine he needed to
support software pipelines
hence the rotating registers in the
Itanium it's it was an early effort and
Bob didn't live long enough to do it
again others yes it's your plan to use
to program this thing using conventional
languages entirely as I say wearing that
to make money we're not trying to sell
somebody a language just want to make
sure no they this is run and see
straight off the web we've been in Sim
for several years and I mean it's you
got nad put the ad in the bundle this is
purely an encoding issue with that what
I've described here doesn't care with
the instruction set is doesn't care
where language is how do you get the
bits apart you probably won't be able to
go into much detail business may not be
something that I love to brag about my
baby there are no general registers the
programmers model and bear in mind this
is a model this is not a physical
reality the model of an x86 is we do one
instruction until it's finished then we
do one instruction until it's finished
but it doesn't work like that on the
inside at all but the programmers model
is this is one at a time the programmers
model on the mill is a belt machine the
communication of data has well you know
how a stack machine works or shove a
value on the stack then you add the top
two M's
conserve the result on on on the batch
but there's no no addressing of operands
you don't have to have register in there
in our situation the programming model
is a conveyor belt all of the operations
dropped their results at the front of
the belton pushers everything else along
if you want to do an ad you can say I
want to this value off of the belt and I
want that value off the belt and they'll
add it together and the result of the ad
will appear in the front of the belt and
everything gets shoved along again now
when I say give me this one and this one
what I'm actually doing is I'm saying
give me the third most recent value that
got dropped on the belt and the fifth
most recent value that got dropped on
the belt because every cycle new things
are being dropped on the belt and the
whole thing is being pushed along so
what we're doing here is not spatial
addressing not register numbers not
memory addresses we're doing temporal
addressing we're saying this sequence in
time its addresses change each cycle the
location is different eventually it
reaches the end of the physical Belton
drops off and if you have a value that
needs to be saved longer well you have
to move it to someplace else and we have
mechanisms for doing this another
professor Pat Perez produces very good
good papers but another one of his
papers he took apart to see what the
average actual dependency life time was
for values produced again huge master
code using a conventional compiler and a
conventional instruction set in
something MIPS I think and he found that
80% of all operation results are used
once at period that's it
14% are used two or more times and 6%
are never used at all in this coding now
as we're dropping things in the belt the
compiler the compiler is scheduling code
dataflow style so that the consumer is
close to the producer in VL I double use
this is a twenty-year-old compiler
technique and we use exactly the same
thing nothing novel there so if the
address produced a result that's going
to be used by a multiply well your
scheduler little old apply as soon as
the results going to be available and
that takes care of your ad and it takes
care of about half of the 14% because a
half of them the Annette the immediately
following consumption is going to be
soon enough that the value is going to
be still on the belt it's only the
values which need to be kept for some
time considerably later that need to be
run off somewhere and that is running
around six or eight percent of all
operands now if you've got physically a
small belt like our low-end of machines
you can't be dropping a whole lot
because things will run off the belt
before you need before you're done with
them if you've got something like that
double gold you need a whopping big
physical belt because you're going to
want to use them before they get to the
end and disappear so there's a a a
configuration trade-off between length
of belt and the amount of work you're
spending running things from the belt
off to temporary storage or scratch pad
and back and that's purely a matter of
configuring a particular member of the
family as to where you want to make that
balance does that mean that the low-end
machine requires a different binary than
the high-end machine or you do you get
that we use another search from IBM I'm
not proud I'll steal from anybody
IBM and in the system 30
I had an awesome and very interesting a
capability architecture but they wound
up changing that architecture several
times at the at the bit level encoding
basis but their mechanism for supporting
that and being able to run the same code
on every member of that they ever built
was that the final step of going from
program to bit encoding was done at
install time or even in some cases at
load time so we are binary compatible as
they were at the load module level but
not at the bit level we've got libraries
which if you want to write a JIT for us
for example you you don't generate the
the bit C's at all you generate our
slightly higher level representation of
what mill code looks like and feed it to
our library our library will give you
bits which is what we ourselves use we
got one over here
your your model as far as belting sounds
to me like I remember systolic arrays
well raishin from them um it is it's
it's of limited length but rather than
feeding directly in a the way systolic
machine would where the data is directly
goes from producer to consumer honor
debt more or less dedicated data path
the on the belt the values have just
dropped on the belt and sixteen people
can pick up the same value all at once
if you've got sixteen ops which the
systolic array can't do that weird
intended for general purpose code where
there's no a priori predictable
structure to what the access pattern is
going to be done I think you mentioned
that there are a lot of calls in any
program one of the main motivators for
risk
way back when was different techniques
of trying to optimize calls parameter
passing berkeley risc spark focused on
register windows that would overlap four
parameters sake 29,000 had a stack of
parameters where you always had access
to some basic point 29 some of the risks
had local register sets and Louisville
register sets no we do not have a local
belt but everybody agrees is that this
is parameter passing is a big issue
getting in and out of teens is important
being able to return multiple values is
something you need to focus on
everything you've said sort of suggests
that there's no obvious parameter
passing convention because well I was
routine who knows what the order was
that put things onto the belt such that
they may not be present in the order
each time in the same way each nine
routine is called well that be degress
very much slightly and tell you and tell
you how a divide works a divide is
logically a two result operation perfect
remainder this is a royal pain in the
button most instruction set
architectures because everything is
designed and encoded for a single result
going to a single register and they use
implicit registers and this and their
that and the other in order to solve the
problem and it's always a clues on a
bell to Caesar
you drop two results that simple this is
what function calls do tip you can have
a function call which produces an R well
not an arbitrarily large it is limited
but a large number of individual results
all your output and in/out parameters
get turned into results for us you've
got text early one result in three and a
three output parameters well that we
just turned that into a function call
with four out of four results all
dropped now to going the other direction
which is to get arguments into the call
the values of your on the belt we will
assume that we've just computed them so
all the values we want on the belt but
they're not our own as
in order and they've got crust from
other operations scattered in the middle
of it so what our call operation is
gives a target address and the belt list
not just one operand not just two
operands but a long list was length is
determined by other matters that don't
matter but typically up to 16 arguments
and it says I want that one and that one
and that one and this one and then I
want this one again and so forth and all
of that winds up being picked up off of
the belt and the call e gets a brand new
to him empty belt with all the arguments
in order this takes place in one cycle
and how we do that is another talk I
think you've heard that before this is
also how the way interrupts work an
interrupt is for us as nothing except
and and in an implicit unexpected
function call and works exactly the same
as our own function operation the
interrupt comes in there's its arguments
and the belt the rest of the remainder
of the other belt is filled with invalid
but you've got to put it back together
again returns again please you've got to
put the belt as I said that's another
talk but yeah
yes you do and as I said in there's not
a whopping big shift register in this
thing trust me there is no big shift
register this is the programming model
this is this big shift register but
there is it one really and actually
internally what it looks like is sort of
like a cross between the content
addressable memory and a bypass network
on a conventional machine that's what it
looks like internally in hardware terms
but that needs slides to explain yes so
debugging must be fun on this machine
debug debugging well like anybody else
the bulk of the debuggers code you want
to do wants to be a line-by-line and if
it's been heavily optimized it's
impossible and that's true for us too
chips are more of a problem because the
JIT has to produce holy bb's which many
Jets don't and we do not support
self-modifying code at all of any
content we've got to produce a whole new
e BB and then get us to move the thing
and into the data path for the
instruction cache anybody who does
self-modifying code deserves it we the
actual debugging itself at the Machine
level if you actually do need to look at
operations yes we have a debugger if you
are thoroughly familiar with the way the
machine works it's easy to use and even
one might say friendly the interface is
the same as GD big we cut we just copy
the the interface not the code for there
but the the way the interface works with
a few minor exceptions to deal with with
some things that GDP doesn't know about
like wide instructions Dave Yost
wherever he is there he is designed and
we have put off implementing a graphic
debugger that will actually let you
watch visually the execution in the
machine instruction by instruction as
things went along and we will probably
do that at some point but guys we're
starving startup we've got limited
resources and things that will be
beautiful for end users need to wait
until we have end users
protection protection yeah not file not
fact I can say that the machine is a
static shared address model it is
intended to run a nano core operating
system and what Steve Jobs thought he
was going to do before I discovered that
existing ships wouldn't do it right and
yes it's got very interesting protection
characteristics including among other
things that it is immune for a large
number of common exploits and it are
simply not physically possible
capabilities or it is not a capability
architecture I wouldn't love to do a
capability architecture I think the cat
caps are the most wonderful thing in the
world I know how to build one and I
don't know how to sell one we're in the
goal to make money okay you mentioned
that interrupts were handled the same
way as calls in one-hitter up model
interrupts just as a hardware and VOC
all the returns to where it was but
there are a lot of other cases where you
might have to save state and restore
state and switch them on threads and do
multitasking or multi-user support or
exceptions that may return where it was
or may return to a handler so what is
the Machine State is it possible to talk
about or to characterize in order to
completely encapsulate where you are go
to something arbitrarily different and
weeks later come back and resume with
everything in there of course its
general purpose code you want
co-routines you want multi thread you
want parallel tests yeah we do all of
those securely
it's the target is the code that you
you're using everyday the quantity of
state in the machine
depends on what model it is the a
machine like that gold with a large
number of functional units some of which
have got large quantities of in-flight
State you know you got a bunch of
multipliers and things halfway through a
multiply and that state
there's the belt itself the bill
contents itself but belt sizes the
smallest felt thrown on our smallest
member is 8 long most of them are 16
some of the high-end are 32 long but
compare those numbers compared to the
number of rename registers or even
physical registers what does the Itanium
got for a register you count like 400 or
something ridiculous like that all over
the state that has to be saved no we
don't do any of that it's it's a quite
low state machine and deliberately done
so we wanted to keep things simple and
and you got enough Stajan but you're
paying in wire length and heat it does
three seconds the i860 failed because
they could save all the Machine State
but had no way to restore it properly as
well pipelines they couldn't access
yeah well it's smoke and mirrors it's
the spark and the more recent Itanium
have the right idea and that is that
programs have got no business mucking
with state that hardware should buck
mistake as hardware knows what the state
is and the biggest single overhead in
most codes on most machines is the
amount of work you have to do to do a
call the preamble of the call and the
called the the preamble in the inside of
the call and what you got
when you're unwanted the other way this
is like a dozen instructions for one car
lot this is ridiculous
so instead do a call well the hardware
knows what you mean by a call give me a
frame and save the state and this and
that and the other let the hardware do
it no reason why the programmer has to
muck with that or the compiler for that
matter that was backs the call
instruction that did everything and as
you recall MIPS react this was a
reaction to the call instruction well if
you consider that the VAX was done with
Flipkart's the major breakthroughs in
our industry have been primarily
breakthroughs not in architecture rather
a little of what we do was not at least
foreshadowed by the IBM stretch and this
gentleman sitting here what worked on
the stretch to 70/30 and he is on in our
team and the he keeps our nose keeps
young whippersnappers like myself from
claiming credit for ideas that are in
fact well known to everybody but me the
the major advances have been packaging
advances not architecture but packaging
the data general Nova was the first
computer that would fit on one circuit
board on a 19-inch rack they build a
company out of that a nice big one the
first processor that you could fit on a
microchip we call that company today
Intel the reason why risk existed had
absolutely nothing to do with the
philosophical merits of risk which the
arguments are pro and con and they're
valid arguments both pro and con the
reason why risks existed is that you
could fit a risk on a chip and you
couldn't fit a non risk
that was a node window that lasted about
two nodes maybe eight years and after
that there's absolutely no excuse for a
classic RISC architecture and sure
enough they've all been migrating more
and more cruft into it unfortunately
they're not doing it from us we starting
from scratch
so it's cruft on top of the of something
else it wasn't intended for it rather
than doing what we are we we've got the
luxury of being able to rethink this
thing completely from scratch we have
gotten no compatibility either mental
emotional philosophical or architectural
issues and when you go back and rethink
something from scratch you wind up with
something like that which is kind of
different
you